you said something else earlier with
Mitt Romney yeah I want everybody to
start at the same level when they get
started right versus it's not fair that
Mitt Romney's kid or Mitt Romney is a
bad example we can use anybody's kids
Paris Hilton Paris Hilton exactly that's
a great example that's the better
example actually to say you know it's
not fair who is she who all of a sudden
hey I'm doing a documentary people want
to watch me look how cool I am
Etc et cetera okay so what should it be
so let's just say I am uh uh the Hilton
family and we got two and a half billion
dollars right money how much of that
[ __ ] end up going to Paris well that's a
that's a good question I think that
needs to be debated by the people and
determined by the people but if you're
asking my personal opinion I want to
know you yeah my personal opinion uh I
think I wouldn't go as far as some of
the revolutionaries to say like she
should literally start with nothing and
inherit nothing I think that's far too
extreme yeah uh but I wouldn't lose a
wink of sleep if she went from having
2.2 billion dollars to let's say having
50 million dollars I think Paris 99 I I
and honestly I think if you this exact
example I think is a good example where
a lot of people would see where I'm
coming from whereas there's others where
it might be a little more go until you
say what give your argument yeah I got a
follow-up to that no I mean because uh
people okay because the way we think of
the economy we we think of it some
people do I should be clear as like it's
a very it's a merit-based thing it's a
meritocracy yeah I don't buy that at all
I think your human value versus your
market value are totally separate things
and we judge everything based on market
value so somebody like Paris Hilton you
know what has she contributed to the
world she's contributed to nothing and
we're gonna feel bad if she inherits 50
million dollars and that's just because
people would look at it on paper and say
well her dad had 2.2 billion or whatever
the [ __ ] and it's like I think she's
gonna be okay with 50 million I think
the people that I'm concerned about are
the people who are busting their ass and
getting absolutely nowhere people who
work two or three full-time jobs and
they don't make enough money to survive
and I think one of the best groups that
you can tax in a society is Rich dead
people to give everybody else a chance
they do taxed Rich dead people
it's a very very tiny number I think it
kicks in fact check me on this I think
it kicks in over 5 million or 11 million
20 million is is
that well it goes back and forth between
uh different administrations uh Bush
pumped it up but it's very hot right
yeah but still you're you know what the
tax when you said point one percent
that's not what they're paying in tax no
no oh I know that no I'm saying
what percentage of people are worth 20
million but do you know what yeah the
estate tax actual amount is do you know
the number 50 70 exactly something like
that yeah so if you're worth 50 million
dollars right there's a 20
uh threshold so that's tax exempt and
now you're paying that 30 additional 30
million additional you have to pay 50 to
the government the death tax number one
you've already been taxed prior to
receiving that money so it's a double
taxation which we can go on for days on
right and how that works so you already
paid the income tax ordinary income tax
or whether it's capital gains what have
you and now speaking of dead people now
you need to pay an additional 50 upon
death but would you say Paris Hilton
earned it that's my question but that's
something I I don't Paris Hilton she
came up with the word that's hot that
went viral good for her awesome but
should the regardless Paris Hilton is
the perfect poster child for someone who
has just lucked out and got the money
correct when I say we stay on the story
okay this is and that's fine yeah yeah
but should the Hilton family that
created Industries hotels jobs you know
Brands everything are you saying that
they should be taxed at 99 forget about
Paris or Nikki or whatever brother or
sister who cares the only reason we know
their name is because she's famous and
she's kind of you know had the the
ability to uh leverage her name to
become famous and kudos for her for that
but you're saying that the family should
be taxed because they've done so well in
this instance I'm specifically talking
about Paris and how much money I think
she could get and clearly I'm pulling
this number out of my ass because you
know okay to come up with a number on
the spot for because I don't know I
actually don't know how much money her
family had I don't know how much money
this isn't I think the audience knows
that we we're just having to come yeah
no no I understand yeah yeah so but but
I think my point is the fact that she's
inheriting 50 million dollars when her
only contribution to society is that
she's part of the lucky sperm club like
I don't feel bad for him and I don't
think she's a victim I don't think she's
oppressed yeah I think if Paris Hilton
got 50 million dollars she wouldn't lose
a wink of sleep and we could actually
and is the more important point take the
money that we're taxing and under a
system that I'm in control of if I was
God Emperor King right what I would do
is I would take that money and put it
towards things that actually about how
people now how much will that move out
of agreement let me come to a point of
agreement with you though I would agree
with you if you say hey let's do this
tax on Paris right now I would say well
I need to see where that money is
actually going to go what are we going
to allocate that money to because if you
say I'm going to take that money I'm
going to turn around and use it to bomb
Afghanistan into Smithereens then I say
you know what we're right we probably
shouldn't do that plan because I don't
want that money going to bomb poor
innocent kids but if you tell me we're
going to take that money and put it
towards whatever fill in the blank a Ubi
program Healthcare then I'd say yeah
that makes sense so then the challenge
with that becomes you're going back to
ESG it's a form of ESG to control where
my money goes to and somebody may say
who the hell are you to decide where my
money should go to so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]